we've been getting a ton of leaks about
Apple's new Apple silicon M3 chip coming
to the MacBook Air which is going to be
amazing because it's going to be on
tsmc's three nanometer process which
means a huge performance boost but it
looks like apple is going to make a
grave mistake apple is apparently
putting this brand new M3 chip into
quite possibly the worst MacBook that we
have right now which is the 13-inch
MacBook Pro so in this video I'm going
to explain why that is such a terrible
idea and I'm gonna theorize why Apple
would possibly think that this is okay
and have actually come up with a couple
of different reasons so let's get right
into the video now getting started with
this bombshell leak which is exclusive
from nine to five mag just a couple of
days ago they said that both the new 13
and 15 inch MacBook Air models are gonna
use the M3 chip and that is a big deal
because for quite a while we've been
getting rumors that it's going to come
with the M2 Chip and maybe even an M2
Pro and that actually lines up to some
rumors that we got last month saying
that the 15-inch MacBook Air would be
set for an early April release which to
us meant that it would be a spring event
however we just got a huge leak from
Mark grimmon who was the most reliable
Apple leaker out there saying that apple
is getting ready to launch some new Macs
including a new iMac but the crazy thing
is he said that apple is scheduled to
launch about three new Macs between late
spring and summer so not early April
like that leak was saying for the 15
inch so that means it's not going to be
coming that soon and here's the problem
Ross young once again even after that
report from Mark German said that the
15-inch is still on track to launch in
April completely going against Mark
German now if it does come in April then
it does make sense for it to come with
the M2 Chip but it looks like no
according to 95 Mac they said both of 13
and 15 will come with the M3 chip which
by far makes the most sense in terms of
a lineup standpoint so the big question
is are these new M3 Max coming this
summer at wwc or are they getting
delayed until the fall I'm not really
sure but the craziest thing about this
leak is that nine to five Max says that
a refreshed MacBook Pro is also in the
works and not just any MacBook Pro it's
actually going to be the 13 inch model
which is codenamed j504 so yes that
leaked as well and it's an entry-level
MacBook Pro model with the same 8 core
M3 as the new Macbook Air is supposed to
get now apparently Apple considered
dropping the pro branding from this
model and just calling it the MacBook
because of course it kind it sucks but
they decided not to do that and they're
still calling it the MacBook Pro so with
that said let me explain why that is
such a terrible terrible idea but first
I've got to show off the single best
external SSD for the Mac in the world
which is this the zeit drive from our
partner zyke it's essentially a
tool-free SSD enclosure that you simply
pop open using your fingers and then you
can easily install your own m.2 nvme SSD
and the reason this one is so special is
that it comes with a very convenient
hidden cable slot and it's the fastest
usb4 SSD enclosure in the world with up
to 3.8 gigabytes per second read speed
and 3.1 gigabytes per second write
speeds with passive cooling just look at
how it compares to some of the most
popular external Thunderbolt ssds on the
market finishing a large 172 gig file
transfer to the drive faster than all of
them and even better it's actually the
cheapest option totaling just 210
dollars for the zyke drive with the
early bird special on Indiegogo and PCI
Express Gen 4 SSD compared to 350
dollars for the runner-up SanDisk G
Drive Pro and the best part is that the
zyk drive is fully upgradable at any
time so check it out using the link in
the description below just by looking at
Apple's website where you can see the
compare Mac models page we have the
MacBook Pro 13 inch on the left and the
MacBook Air M2 right here in the middle
first of all you can see that you get
more finishes on the MacBook Air Model
but the MacBook Pro is
12.99 a hundred dollars more expensive
and the issue with that is it's using
the old design that is way outdated you
can see it has the big black bezels all
the way around especially at the top
compared to the new M2 MacBook Air which
has thin bezels that are rounded along
the edges with the notch so it looks
much more modern and of course the 13
inch MacBook Pro has the touch bar which
I can't stand I hate having it I love
having those function keys on the new
Macbook Air and even worse the old
MacBook Pro Design has the 720p webcam
which everybody hated compared to the
really nice looking 1080p version that
we have now in the MacBook Air and
getting even worse that old MacBook Pro
Design is lacking one of the things that
I love the most on the new Air which is
the max save 3 connector which is so
awesome because it enables fast charging
and it frees up the other Thunderbolt
ports so you can use them for
accessories instead of having to use one
dedicated for charging and honestly that
old design shouldn't even be called a
MacBook Pro because if you look at the
higher end models like the 14 inch and
the 16 inch those designs are on a whole
another level they look absolutely
amazing with much better displays with
120 hertz Pro motion Technology support
and a bunch of extra ports and macsafe
they're on a whole nother level compared
to the 13 inch which doesn't even
deserve to be called a pro model so now
the issue is that old design that sucks
we honestly don't recommend it to
anybody we've been telling people to buy
the MacBook Air because of the design
forget about everything else the design
matters the most because you don't want
to feel like you're outdated with this
old design so the big question is why in
the world would Apple give their brand
new M3 chip that is super fast awesome
with three nanometer technology from
tsmc why why would they give that ship
to that old design MacBook Pro they
should have just canceled it completely
but nope nine to five Max says that it
is coming with verification from
multiple sources well I actually have
four reasons for why Apple would do this
and the first one is giving people a
MacBook Pro at a lower thirteen hundred
dollar price point because then they can
advertise that Apple's MacBook Pros
start at 12.99 so it's just a way to say
that they have a lower priced MacBook
Pros for marketing number two is by
offering a really bad outdated product
with the M3 chip that would actually
make the M3 MacBook Air look a lot
better so it's almost like giving people
a choice do you want this crappy old
outdated model or this really nice one
and then when they look at the old one
the newer nicer MacBook Air looks a lot
better and it might actually push people
to buy more of them number three is that
maybe it's actually going to perform
better with the fan now that fan was the
only reason that apple had for
continuing the M2 MacBook Pro old design
they said the fan allows it to have
higher performance and yes of course it
does have slightly better performance so
what if the M3 Chip is going to be super
super fast and what if it's going to be
limited in the MacBook Air chassis which
has passive cooling maybe that's enough
justification for Apple to release this
old 13-inch MacBook Pro model and I
don't think that the 15-inch air is
getting a fan either I think it's going
to be almost identical to the smaller
13-inch air so that means fanless so you
basically only have the 14 inch MacBook
Pro that comes with a fan at two
thousand dollars so maybe Apple wants to
offer a cheaper version with a fan and
for reason number four it's simply
because Apple can it's going to be cheap
efficient and easy for Apple to just
switch out the M3 chip into that model
put it back on the market even though it
doesn't make sense just a simple chip
swap and that's it it's easy for them to
do and they're gonna have a bigger
lineup I guess with the M3 chip inside
of it but in my personal opinion I think
it makes sense for Apple to just scrap
that model start off with the regular M2
MacBook Air then the 15 inch then the 14
and 16 on the high end and it's going to
be much more simple and I think that's
the way to go but maybe you disagree
with me let me know down in the comment
section below thanks for watching and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
foreign